nitey I teach undergraduates and
graduate students some of the courses I
offer our offer are open to both in the
last over the last three years about
three-quarters of my teaching have been
some courses in quantitative methods and
statistics data analysis methods and
statistics and I teach I teach a 4000
level course that has both graduate
students and undergraduates in and also
I also the students some of the courses
graduate the gratitude to take the
courses are from all over the university
there from there from from ciba Teachers
College socio Medical Sciences public
health school social work and a lot of
the masters programs in in the social
sciences the political science and
quantitative methods quantitative
quantitative methods social sciences
master's degree program in addition to
undergraduates in the 4000 level course
the 92 3000 level course introductory
course on unstick tante data analysis
and statistics for political science
with research that's undergraduates only
and what do you think as a professor
what's the most important thing you can
do for for students or
oh I mean both I mean the most important
thing is it is to kind of well once
they're in the class the kind of motor
motor motivate them to kind of kind of
stay in the class and you know learn
about the application of quantitative
methods to show the usefulness of it to
show that the methods aren't simply
mechanical statistical methods that you
apply in a vacuum but rather their
methods that are employed to answer
research questions so you start not with
the statistics you start with the
research question you want to examine
and then proceed that to proceed to
figure out how you're going to answer
that question using quantitative
quantitative approaches and in
particular the most interesting kinds of
questions are questions that involve
narratives or stories about cause and
effect relationships and what I try to
do is this dude is to show how data
could be utilized and statistical
methods can be applied to kind of gain
some insight about the possibilities of
reaching conclusions about how some
variable X affect some variable some
variable Y relevant the politics are
irrelevant to anything that they might
be relevant anything might be interested
so it's the motivational part and then
also a big part of this sort of
confidence ability to show it to show
the students particularly those who were
not so mathematically and statistically
inclined that you know this kind of work
is is doable and as they start doing it
they kind of build confidence and the
proof it you know the proof of how well
I'm doing is to what extent the students
then go on to take other courses beyond
the ones that I offer I offer two
semester sequences students take both
courses
often take both courses and then the big
question is will they do any more